هل يشتري المال السعاده الاجابه نعم طبقا
للعلم على الاقل دراسه امريكيه جديده
نشرتها الاكاديميه الوطنيه للعلوم تحدد
درجات السعاده او سقف معين للسعاده البحث
الشمل اكثر من 33 الف شخص يعيشون في
الولايات المتحده ويحصلون على اجر سنوي
يعادل 10,000 كحد ادنى كما هو متوقع وجدت
نتائجنا الشعور بالسعاده يوصل لارتفاع
كلما ارتفع الدخل لدى معظم الناس لكن
المثير الانتباهنا الباحثين لاحظوا ان
اقليه من المشاركين توقف ارتفاع معدل
شعورهم بالسعاده عندما وصلوا الى حد معين
من الدخل العالي طبق الاغلبيه على ان مئه
الف دولار سنويا يكفي للوصول الى سقف
السعاده واي زياده في الدخل بعدها لا تصنع
فارقا كبيرا
[موسيقى]
العلماء اتفقوا ان المال يجلب السعاده هل
تتفق مع العلماء
اني بتفرج على اشي معين الكركر او السعاده
اللي احنا بنقول على المترجم من كتر ما
انت بتضحكي بتصير الدمعي من عينك او تصير
تطلع من المعده فهي ممكن تكون السعاده في
واحد بقول لك اني اساعد الناس مع احترامي
للكل خلاص هذه سعادتك
انا اللي بقرر هذا الشيء هو اللي بيسعدني
مش ما في مقياس زي جدول الضرب اني اقول لك
2 × 2 بيطلع اربعه
فكلهيتها نسبيه اضافه الى هذه المعايير
الظروف دكتور الى اي مدى تؤثر على
استعادتنا كيف يمكن ان نكون في مكان سعداء
في مكان ثاني تعسى الحاله تبعتي انا هي
هادئه كلها ممكن نروح نقعد على البحر
وكله هيتنا نروح نقعد على البحر انا بحب
الاثنين في ناس بتقول لك لا انا قعدت البر
اللي هي المقصود فيها الصحراء والرمال
والهذه الاشياء انا بجيب الاكتئاب انا
بتضايق انا كذا طيب في ناس بنروح بقول لهم
طيب قعدت البحر كلها ممكن احنا الثلاثه
نروح او اربعه غيرنا اي اشخاص الروح كلها
نقعد في نفس الاماكن بس كل واحد ياخد
[موسيقى]